And Fox
News has
agreed to pay an enormous
a historic price
for broadcasting conspiracy theories
about the 2020 election.
The network
reaching a last minute settlement
with Dominion voting systems
for more than $787 million.
They struck the right agreement
that struck the agreement
I should say right before
right before the defamation
trial was about to begin.
Dominion's lawyers
say it's a victory
for truth and democracy.
Dominion tells CNN
that the deal does not require
Fox News anchors to go on air
and tell viewers that they lied.
Here's what Fox said in a statement.
When the news broke
I do have a statement from Fox, Neil.
We are pleased to have reached
a settlement
of our dispute
with Dominion Voting Systems.
We acknowledge the court's rulings
finding certain claims about Dominion
to be false.
This settlement reflects Fox's
continued commitment
to the highest journalistic standards.
We just want to give you
now a small sample of the broadcast
that got Fox News broadcasts
that got Fox News in trouble. Here it is,
Sidney.
We talked about the Dominion software.
I know that there were
voting irregularities.
Tell me about that.
Electronic voting machines
didn't allow people to vote, apparently,
and that whatever
you think of it, the cause of it,
it shakes people's faith in the system
that is an actual threat to democracy.
And this morning,
we're hearing from the CEO of Dominion
Voting Systems.
Watch this
There was an acknowledgment
and certainly it's not
the way I wrote it.
And I had some conversations with
our team.
My co-founder and I
and at the end of the day,
the court system
really is about accountability.
We feel we got it
and all of the facts
that we had discovered
during the case
had already come to light.
Joining us now,
lead counsel for Dominion, Justin Nelson.
Justin,
thank you so much
for your time this morning.
Thank you. Good morning.
Hi.
Good morning.
I think one of the big questions
this morning is sort of
how do you put a price tag on
trust in US democracy? Right.
You can't put a price on that,
as one of our colleagues writes on CNN
this morning.
Was this about money for Dominion
or was this about truth?
Well, I think it was really our two
goals were accountability.
And to get compensation for this
massive amount of harm
that occurred to the company.
And I think we achieved
both on the truth, on the accountability.
Over the past few months,
you've seen this mountain of evidence
that has been revealed
and texts and emails
that really show that, in fact,
Fox knew Fox knew that it was lies.
And the statement that Fox released
yesterday acknowledged
the court's order
that called these false.
This was the first time
that a court has held
that the election lies
were, in fact, lies.
And this was the first time that someone
has been held accountable
in the form
of a nearly $800 million payment
for that.
It is also, of course,
a civil litigation,
and it's about making my client whole.
And although this does not make my client
a whole, it is a step in that direction.
And instead of going for years to appeal
and to a verdict,
we got an $800 million settlement,
nearly $800 million settlement.
And we're proud of what we did.
And we do think it's a victory
both for truth and for accountability.
Let's talk a little bit
more about that, Justin,
because in the statement,
I mean, Fox says this is just part of it.
We acknowledge
the court's
rulings
finding certain claims
about Dominion to be false.
They didn't exactly say that,
that they lied.
And there is
among the public,
there is a feeling
that it may have been better.
Justin, for the Fox News anchors
and their leaders or management
to take the stand,
to acknowledge the lies publicly
that that would have sent
a stronger message.
What do you say to that?
Well, I would say that
there was that acknowledgment.
And I would also say
that in the civil litigation system,
we could have gotten a ten 20 billion
you name the billion dollar award,
and they still wouldn't
have had to apologize or to go on air
to say that they were wrong.
What we can do in a civil
litigation system
is to bring accountability
by exposing the truth
and by having compensation for the harm
that occurred.
And on that,
we accomplish both by a wide margin.
Would you have preferred
if you could have gotten your druthers
to have the Fox News anchors and
folks on air say you know what, we lied
or at least
bit having to have them to have them
have to make a statement?
Would you prefer that
It's always bittersweet when
you settle a case
because you think you have a great case.
The issue is,
of course, that there's always risk in
going to a jury trial.
And my client, really
these employees of Dominion
have been so incredibly harmed
and they still get threats, death
threats.
They it's really difficult
for the company to be operating.
And so for them to have this settlement
really does mean a lot And remember,
this is just the first step.
We have six
other cases against other defendants
who are
some of them
are still lying about the election.
And so what we think
and we're really proud of
is that this really is
the first time that someone has been held
accountable for the results
and the lies that we're told
after the 20, 20 election
Other defendants who might that be
Well, we have a case against Newsmax.
We have a case against one American news.
And then of course,
we have cases against Sidney Powell
and Mike Lindell and Mypillow
and Rudy Giuliani and Patrick Byrne.
And so we think that
we will continue
to hold people accountable
for the lies that they told.
I mean, look,
ultimately misinformation
is not going away.
The truth does not know red or blue.
And what we have to do
is really
if we're going to have this
shared experiment in democracy,
we have to have a common commitment
to facts.
And we can disagree.
We can have different opinions,
even on our most profound issues.
But if we are not able to agree on facts,
then that is
when we're going to have these
just bubbles of what
we don't talk to each other.
And what happened to Dominion
is it just got swept
in this torrent of lies
where it was
in this alternative universe.
And I do hope that this really does
send a message
that it is so, so important
to tell the truth
and that if you don't tell
the truth, lies have consequences.
And I think this is what it established.
And that is why
there is accountability today.
There's accountability to dominion
and there's accountability to democracy.
Justin.
Former Fox News anchor Gretchen
Carlson tweeted a few days ago.
Please do not settle.
You are about to prove something
very big.
She, of course, was successful
not only against
in her litigation against Fox News,
but in arbitration,
but in changing the law
when it comes to secret
mandatory arbitration.
I just wonder
if there are things about Fox as lies
and how they conducted themselves
behind closed doors.
But now the public will not know
because there has been
there will be no trial
Well,
I think that what you saw
in the past
couple of months
that has come out
in our summary judgment briefing
and that already is
public, has really revealed
behind the scenes that Fox did know
that these were lies.
That was a really big question.
Going into this.
Did Fox really know it?
Did the anchors who are saying
it really believe it?
And I think that we've seen the evidence.
We've seen the evidence
from these crazy emails
that started it all to people
saying that Sidney Powell was lying to
the motive that occurred.
And this was all in black and white
and documents that have been revealed.
So would
the trial have put on that same evidence?
Of course.
But at the end of the day,
I think the accountability came
from what already has happened
over the last months.
And, of course, the payment itself,
having a nearly $800 million payment,
really, I think sends a strong message
about what it means to lie.
Justin Nelson, thank you for your time.
We'll be following those,
I think six other cases
that you are
lead counsel
in as well as this progresses.
Thanks very, very much Thanks, Justin.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.